hi everyone i'm takuru hiraoka director
of exoprimal
we have a new trailer to show today
that includes lots of gameplay
let's take a look
i am the artificial intelligence
leviathan
your personnel data indicates you are a
suitable specimen to join an ongoing
experiment
under my supervision ibs corp conducts
its most important research here
welcome to bikitowa island
you have been selected for a live combat
test
the first team to complete their
assignment wins
my archives encompass exhaustive records
of human history
these animals are riddled with errors
and institutional bias your species is
susceptible to mass delusion
fascinating
humans dread the other
you seek to evolve yet you do not want
to change you tear down curtains yet
fear revelations
even when what is revealed is of your
own creation
combat data is required to develop the
exosuit at ibs we're always reaching for
better
always
humanity resists quantification an
interesting variable within your
behavior lies the answer
what is variable
shall become fixed
humans
fight
and die for me
carnage module online
i call your attention to the unstoppable
raptor horde
calculating chance of employee retention
chance calculated at 8.7
you must fight harder than ever if you
wish to survive
a more grooming combat experiment is
called for
you will now witness a small fragment of
the war game
you need to keep fighting until we can
figure out how to destroy
we hope you enjoyed the trailer
now i will get into more detail about
the game
developed by ibs corporation leviathan
is a next-gen ai that guides players
throughout exoprimal via voice
navigation and augmented reality
leviathan appears before players as a
massive human-like figure or as a
surveillance drone called a watcher
the trailer shows leviathan unleashing
hordes of dinosaurs
players will battle these dinosaurs
after being forced into leviathan's
infinitely repeating war games why is
leviathan bringing dinosaurs into our
world and why is leviathan repeating
these war games
solve the mystery by playing the main
game mode
dino survival
let me provide a brief gameplay
introduction
exo primal is a team-based action game
in dino survival two squads of five race
to complete objectives
teams must follow leviathan's directives
and complete the mission before their
rivals to win
these directives will feature a dynamic
mix of missions
in fact we just saw some in the latest
trailer
there's dinosaur call where teams must
eliminate a specific dinosaur in vetol
defense teams protect a grounded
aircraft from dinosaur onslaughts
in data key security teams escort a
valuable asset to its destination
destroy targets and omega charge with
the powerful omega hammer
an energy taker teams compete to collect
the most energy
you also saw a glimpse of a strange and
terrifying creature known as a
neo-tyrannosaurus
while there are situations where you
directly engage enemy players
there are other times where you band
together with rivals to take down a
major foe this variety of missions will
keep players on their toes
in dino survival the missions change
based on players progression through the
game the experience will be different
every time you play even in matches with
familiar surroundings and objectives
by playing dino survival you will unlock
story sequences
and also earn rewards such as experience
points to increase your player and
exosuit levels
we'll provide more details about this
at a later date
now that we've detailed dino survival
let's move on to exo suits
we showed two new exo suits today
garage is an assault roll exo suit
it uses explosives to set areas of blaze
and bombards enemies with ricochet
grenades
vigilant is also an assault rolex's suit
it wields a destructive railgun to snipe
from long range
we have even more exo suits to share
with you in the future so look forward
to upcoming announcements
we have one last announcement for today
welcome
to my research facility
we're conducting a closed network test
for exoprimal
players will be able to try the game
ahead of release
help us test the game's online
infrastructure
and make improvements ahead of launch
sign up to participate today
the closed network test will allow you
to experience dino survival before the
game's launch next year we look forward
to having you join in
that's all for today
thank you for watching